Spirit Awards you're an expert now
you've studied all these movies what do
you think's the most overlooked movie in
2018 I mean there are so many movies I'm
so excited to celebrate all the films
but I would have to say that my my
honestly my favorite movie of the year
is a movie that is not nominated for
anything it was nominated for one award
for the Oscars hair and makeup
it's called border and it's disorder yes
it's a Swedish film called border that I
was introduced to in the fall and it
blew my mind I thought wow I can't
really say even though I have nothing to
do with the movie I have no business
talking about it someone told me about
just before the you came out here that
you brought a clip did you bring a clip
this movie no to do it okay the people
that own the movie were like well if you
love it so much you know we'll buy out a
theater for you and you can host a
screening of the film and show all your
friends so I was like it's on let's do
it let's get a theater let's get this
going they booked a theater for me I got
60 people to come and I'm thinking all
I'm gonna have to do tonight is just say
like you're welcome here's border and
introduce the film but is going to say
you're welcome do what I say at the
beginning of every show every night hi
everybody you're welcome
it's not my movie I'm not saying I made
it I don't nothing to do with it I'm
saying here's a gift of a thing that I
think is good and you'll like it too so
you're welcome anyway that didn't happen
because this incredibly long story but
the short version is this I got to the
theater someone that was supposed to be
setting up the screening for me was
there practically crying shaking and and
telling me we don't have it it's not
here the movies not here meanwhile I've
got 60 people you know coming up the
street chanting bordure but what is true
is that that they didn't have the movie
and I have all these people milling
around in the lobby so I had to stand on
top of the popcorn machine and basically
go listen oh and by the way I'm drunk
because I thought I'd not to do anything
well I ain't drunk because I said I
thought out all I would have to do is
stand up and say have a great time
everybody you're welcome and sit down
but now I find myself giving a speech
then I had to stand up on the machine
and go listen this movie's not happening
it's not here this has never happened in
the history of screenings I don't know
what to tell you go home in the middle
of my speech they said wait a minute
it's here and I was like oh my god you
guys there's been an update it is here
everyone go into the theater we're gonna
watch borders so they all go board it
happened no it didn't happen and here's
why
you say this is the short version of
this story you can edit this make it
better but okay just let me finish the
story please please okay so then
everyone goes into the theater I'm like
when is that when is it gonna come on
and then they tell me actually it's
gonna be like 20 30 minutes so then 20
minutes goes by nothing 30 minutes goes
by and nothing 40 minutes goes by and
people starting to get restless and I'm
going I got to give these people show
they're waiting to see border and what
is happening and they're going we don't
have it yet
fred armisen and Nick Kroll were in the
audience among these people so I went up
to them and I said listen you guys have
to go on I don't know what you're gonna
do you've got to get up there and get
these people in the show with no warning
you just said you got to give them a
show literally no no of course not I
didn't know what to do I was freaking
out
yes she was drunk yes so I said please
you know help me you know what can we do
and then I said I'm gonna introduce you
as the director Fred just pretend to be
the director of border so I I swear this
is a true
so I went up I made another speech and I
said surprise everybody the director of
border is here ally Abbasi is here
please welcome him we're gonna do a
quick Q&A before we start the movie
crawl and Fred come on stage Fred
pretends to be this Swedish film
director starts proles moderating the
Q&A starts asking starts asking the
audience for questions and Fred's going
on going there were 300 takes we did 200
takes for that you know making stuff up
and yeah it's all sweaty and weird and
I'm freaking out and basically that went
on for a long time and you know it got
weird and and then basically after I
don't know an hour I said to the theater
like is this happening or not these
people you know it's been an hour and
they said it's not happening we couldn't
figure it out and I was like this is
unbelievable so then they put on
Suspiria and and
so here they can all watch Suspiria but
the most insane thing is that most of
the people in the audience said all
right fine we'll watch the spiria that's
great an hour into Suspiria without
warning me they turned off Suspiria and
started playing border after there
anyway it was crazy but you guys got to
see this movie I have nothing to do with
it
didn't you bring a clip roll the clip
from border please tonight a local man
[ __ ] on the bed
now now can we see a clip from Suspiria
[Laughter]